(Ilana)
What?
(knocking)
(Ilana)
Let me in.
It's just me.
Okay.
So it's bad.
I'm sorry this
is happening to you.
On the one night that Jeremy
comes over to my apartment,
I explode.
Like, I mean,
this is the worst.
This is the best.
This is a sexy
situation.
It's terrifying
outside.
There's candles
all lit.
And who's
your competition?
Marla Bevers?
Abbi, I'm going to take
care of this for you.
There's no way--
I am a
doo doo ninja.
What does that
even mean?
You-- You do...
Do you grant
me permission
to use any means necessary
to make this go away?
Sure, fine.
Look me in the eyes and
tell me I have your permission.
You have my
permission.
Any means necessary?
Any means necessary.
Great.
Awesome...
Now get out there,
bounce some little titties
for that hunky, quarter-Latino
and whatever else he is.
I dunno.
Okay-- Thank you.
Hey.
Gimme.
Oh my God,
thank you.
Okay.
(gasping)
Oh Lord.
(exhales deeply)
Hold up.
Oh.
Yeah!